l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 349 de Monsieur Christian
Cambon à madame la ministre de
l'Artisanat du Commerce et du Tourisme
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues par un très
heureux hasard de circonstances en fait
ma question
va recouper une partie de celle que mon
collègue alain GOURNAC vient d'évoquer
car c'est les mêmes sujets sur un autre
secteur en effet les cris successives
que vient de connaître l'agroalimentaire
un site de plus en plus de consommateurs
à rechercher la transparence sur
l'origine les composants et la qualité
gustative des produits qu'ils achètent
ou qu'ils consomment notamment dans les
restaurants or dans ces temps de crise
économique nous devons bien évidemment
tout faire ça vient d'être rappelé pour
promouvoir la qualité de nos productions
elle représente en effet sur le plan
économique un secteur porteur de
création d'emplois de formation pour nos
jeunes et de déboucher à l'exportation
aussi dans mon département le mine de
Rungis est la vitrine par excellence de
ce savoir-faire français qui fournit nos
Dét nos collectivités locales et nos
restaurants et du reste cette qualité
vient d'être récompensée puisque le
repas gastronomique français a été
classé au patrimoine mondial immatériel
de l'Unesco en 2011 or ce dernier
secteur subit une évolution qui nous
inquiète en effet pour des raisons
pratiques parfois économiques ou même
financières de plus en plus de
restaurants proposent différentes sortes
de cuisine très différentes qui ne
respectent pas totalement ces valeurs de
la gastronomie française à la vérité il
existe trois modes de cuisine préparés
dans nos restaurants le réchauffage
l'assemblage et la cuisine maison le
réchauffage consiste comme son nom
l'indique à décongeler des produits
surgelés à les réchauffer à réchauffer
des plats sous vide ou le contenu de
boîte de conserve on peut donc déguster
dans certains restaurants du bord de
notre Méditerranée une soupe de poisson
qui n'a strictement rien à voir avec la
pêche du jour mais qui devient de boîte
de conserve et ce sans en avoir aucune
connaissance de la même manière la
traditionnelle tarte tatin peut avoir
été fraîchement décongelé d'un fabricant
industriel dont nous renseignements les
sa pensée qu'ils tiennent en quelque
sorte le monopole de ce magnifique
produit lorsqu'il est bien travaillé
l'assemblage est une pratique qui permet
de servir dans une même assiette des
produits qui n'ont pas été cuisinés sur
place ou qui ne le sont que
partiellement et enfin la cuisine maison
pour laquelle de nombre de nos artisans
de notre restaurateurs se battent avec
courage cette cuisine maison elle
respecte le savoir-faire de repas
entièrement confectionné sur place et
basé sur des produits frais
faute de label précis malheureusement le
consommateur ne s'y retrouve pas et
risque donc là aussi comme pour le pain
de perdre confiance
de surcroît la crise du secteur avec une
baisse de dépenses de 2% en volume en
2012 ne risque de ne pas améliorer les
choses en 2013 la restauration
commerciale devra composer avec un
relèvement de sa taxe sur la valeur
ajoutée qui va passer de 7 à 10% en 2014
et par conséquent la difficulté des
restaurateurs qui veulent faire ce
travail maison pourrait bien évidemment
profiter aux industriels de
l'agroalimentaire puisque la cuisine
d'assemblage assure des performances
économiques évidemment beaucoup plus
élevé alors pour lutter contre ce
phénomène et un peu parallèlement à ce
qui a été fait par les artisans autour
du pain des restaurateurs se mobilisent
pour valoriser leur savoir-faire et leur
travail sous différents labels ainsi
depuis février dernier en région
Île-de-France le centre régional de
valorisation et d'innovation agricoles
et alimentaires a lancé un label
intitulé
des produits d'ici cuisinés ici ce qui
est tout à fait clair les restaurateurs
signataires de cette charte doivent
utiliser en priorité des matières
premières issues de l'Agriculture
d'Île-de-France appartenir au secteur de
la restauration commerciale
traditionnelle et transformer eux-mêmes
les produits frais dans la cuisine de
leur restaurant ce nouveau label
régional vient s'ajouter à d'autres
labels déjà mis en place dans
différentes régions par les
restaurateurs eux-mêmes ce qui
paradoxalement ne favorise pas la
compréhension des consommateurs et donc
ma question est très simple afin d'aider
les consommateurs à mieux comprendre ce
qu'ils vont trouver dans leur assiette
ne faudrait-il pas mettre en place un
label national validé par l'État au même
titre que les étoiles pour les hôtels
puisque là il y a une grille avec des
critères nationaux et qui fait que
n'importe quel personne qui veut se
faire héberger dans un hôtel c'est
lorsqu'un hôtel fait trois étoiles dans
n'importe quel coin du territoire elle
sait à quoi elle est en mesure donc
Madame ministre madame la ministre je
voudrais simplement savoir quelle mesure
vous entendez prendre dans le cadre de
vos projets pour permettre de valoriser
la cuisine faite sur place et le travail
des restaurateurs qui ne sont pas
toujours les plus grands il y a ici du
reste un peu une petite encabre d'ici
quelques petits restaurants qui se
donnent à mal de fous pour promouvoir
cette cuisine et donc quelle mesure
comptez-vous prendre pour promouvoir ce
travail des restaurateurs qui
s'attachent à maintenir les vraies
valeurs de la gastronomie française je
vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
nous avoir mis en appétit madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
valorisé la qualité dans la restauration
et comme vous une de mes priorités c'est
bien dans cet objectif que conformément
aux engagements du Président de la
République j'ai mené un bilan avec les
organisations représentatives des
professionnels du secteur de la
restauration sur le contrat d'avenir
nous avons constaté que ce contrat
d'avenir n'avait pas répondu à
l'ensemble des questions que vous avez
notamment posé sur la qualité sur la
transformation et la fabrication sur
place nous avons donc en lien avec les
organisations professionnelles décider
de définir une méthode de travail et
j'aurai le plaisir d'installer
prochainement un comité stratégique de
la filière restauration pour travailler
avec les professionnels sur l'ensemble
des sujets celui que vous évoquez bien
sûr mais également celui du dialogue
social des conditions de travail des
modernisations de nos restaurants de des
créations d'emplois vous l'avez souligné
c'est un secteur qui recrute qui forme
aussi de nombreux jeunes apprentis et
nous devons accompagner ces
professionnels et discuter de l'ensemble
des préoccupations que nous avons évoqué
donc tous les sujets seront traités dans
ce comité stratégique pour la filière
restauration et j'espère que nous nous
aurons avec les professionnels la
possibilité de travailler sur la qualité
et sur la transformation des produits
dans nos restaurants mais à partir de ce
constat nous avons quand même un certain
nombre de pistes déjà qui de travail qui
existent une des premières réponses qui
a été donnée par l'État pour répondre à
cette exigence de qualité pour les
consommateurs c'est le titre de Maître
Restaurateur il vise à distinguer les
professionnels de la restauration
traditionnelle sur la base d'une
qualification professionnelle et du
respect d'un cahier des charges très
précis basé sur une forte exigence de
qualité celui-ci impose en particulier
la cuisine faite sur place à partir de
produits majoritairement frais sans plat
préparé au niveau de l'accueil les
clients des clients ils prévoient la
présence d'au moins un personnel de ça
le titulaire d'un CAP Restaurant d'un
titre homologué ou de deux ans
d'expérience l'exigence est également
élevée pour les aménagements intérieurs
qui doivent être soignés et
l'environnement extérieur et bien sûr
des conditions d'hygiène doit être
respectées malheureusement nous
constatons aujourd'hui que ce titre de
Maître Restaurateur n'a pas connu le
succès escompté puisque j'ai remis le 12
novembre dernier le 2 millième titre de
Maître Restaurateur c'est insuffisant
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite que dans le cadre du comité de
filière nous puissions travailler
à la rénovation de ce titre non pas pour
baisser l'exigence de qualité mais
peut-être et c'est sûrement une piste de
travail pour simplifier le cahier des
charges pour le rendre plus accessible
aux professionnels puisque lorsqu'on
regarde de manière concrète le dossier
pour être labellisé maître restaurateur
on s'aperçoit que les professionnels de
petites ou de très petites entreprises
peuvent être un petit peu effrayées par
la masse et le nombre de formulaires
administratifs à remplir donc nous
devons travailler en lien avec les
organisations professionnelles pour
rendre plus accessible ce titre de
Maître restaurateur qui sera une
première solution une première réponse
que nous pouvons apporter pour à la fois
bien sûr valoriser le travail de ces
professionnels mais aussi rassurer les
consommateurs qui bien sûr ont le droit
de connaître dans le restaurant qu'il
fréquente si les produits ont été
transformés fait sur place
issus de l'agriculture locale de
proximité c'est un tout ce comité de
filière devra répondre à l'ensemble de
ces questions vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur nous partageons là aussi une
priorité et je l'ajoute que la fête de
la gastronomie qui aura lieu en
septembre doit aussi permettre aux
professionnels d'expliquer au public aux
consommateurs leur savoir-faire leur
excellence et surtout leur passion merci
madame la ministre monsieur Cambon
merci Madame la Ministre merci des
indications précises que vous venez de
nous donner en plus tout le monde
comprendra que c'est un sujet plutôt
consensuel et je pense que
sur tous les bancs de cette assemblée il
y a la volonté singulièrement au Sénat
assemblée des territoires de porter haut
les couleurs de notre gastronomie je
pense que les indications que vous
oui ou alors sans ça il faut ne manger
que de la raclette comme chez le
président de la séance là on peut pas
tricher car on est obligé d'amener le
fromage et la machine sur place plus
sérieusement ce que je veux dire Madame
madame la ministre dans l'approche qui
est la vôtre de Maître Restaurateur je
pense que c'est une très bonne évolution
mais il ne faut pas rester uniquement
focalisé sur la qualité des hommes même
si elle est importante j'ai eu
l'occasion moi de conduire
l'apprentissage en Île de France et
d'aider tous ces jeunes à acquérir ses
qualifications mais c'est surtout le
travail des produits frais je suis
stupéfait de voir que dans des
établissements de prestige on utilise
malheureusement encore trop souvent et
on aurait beaucoup de surprises sur ce
sujet des éléments qui sont
pré-confectionnés et donc on ne fait que
de l'assemblage alors que parfois on a
des petits restaurants qui mettent
beaucoup de qui mettent beaucoup de
force et d'efforts à faire en sorte de
confectionner sur place le repas donc
c'est dans le maniement j'allais dire le
travail autour de la fraîcheur des
produits qu'il est important de faire
avancer les choses en tous les cas
sachez que toutes les initiatives que le
gouvernement portera dans ce domaine
aura bien évidemment notre concours et
notre assentiment je vous remercie
madame la ministre merci Monsieur Cambon
pour cette promotion de la raclette mais
n'oubliez pas la fondue
mes chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance quelques instants en attendant
l'arrivée